so stranger things season two there is
so much hype
coming into this season that if you're
any reasonable fan
you have to lower your expectations
immediately
it was such a surprise hit season one
there was so much riding on this but i
told myself
enjoy what it is you love these
characters steven
take it in so before i get to my final
aim thoughts about this season
i'm gonna break down some stuff that i
really liked and i'm gonna say my number
one thing i liked
was how amazing it was to watch will in
this season he was
just used last season as a plot device
but this season
he murdered it as an actor especially at
that age
so impressive he deserves an award for
this for sure he really put on an acting
clinic
i think he proved just in this season
that he could
perform any emotion you ask of him as an
actor and the places he can go
in his head emotionally to get there for
a certain scene was remarkable
i mean he was out acting winona ryder in
every scene he was in with her that's no
disrespect to her but that's just
showing you
she's an experienced trained actor and
this is this little guy
young and he's killing it i wonder if
when they casted him in season one
did they assume they're gonna need a
really good will for season two someone
can act all this very intense work if
you know the answer to that please
comment below because i'm very curious
but man his scenes
especially when he was on the ground he
was like freaking out and he was
getting attacked by the monster and was
going through him oh
man that is so impressive somebody's in
the hospital bed and he's playing like a
will taken over by the monster
he's doing everything and he was just
blowing me away
so props to him that was a bright spot
cause i was worried about that because
we hadn't seen what will had
and wasn't gonna mess up the chemistry
but he didn't he was really good here
another great thing and this is obvious
because i know everyone's thinking this
but steve harrington
was the rock star this season most
likeable
i like that they made him likeable
because you're worried about them
bringing back his character like he's
gonna be good
and he got better at the end of season
one but we're like how is this gonna
work
it was great i love that it is the bow
the nails it's kind of negan-esque if
you watch walking dead
it's not the barbed wire but it's the
nail so it's pretty cool and he rocks it
with that thing he did in season one he
did again here
he was the best babysitter you can ask
for i think my favorite scene of this
season
was in the junkyard with dustin max and
lucas
and he's going out of the trailer being
brave because he was the oldest
fighting the monsters head-on and he was
a great mentor to dustin and him and
dustin together was my favorite duo of
the season
it worked the best not just because it
was funny but it made sense
and they both learned kind of from each
other in a way in a weird way
it was kind of a good place to put steve
harrington while this other nancy said
was going with her
jonathan but i want to see more of that
steve harrington dustin i would watch a
show adjust them too that was really
good stuff and really good chemistry as
well and another positive which i was
also worried about at first was seeing
sean astin cast in it because it's like
okay
they have the former goonie this is
gonna be fan service now but it wasn't
he was great
his character bob so likable you didn't
know about him at first you're like is
he someone you could trust
because he kind of pitched a little
sketchy when he was helping will out and
being that lovable
figure for will that he didn't have
father figure that was really good he
was hysterical the way he was playing
that goofy guy was kind of just a normal
dude
playing bob and i think the funniest
part of the season was when jonathan and
will were talking about some of their
favorite music
and how david bowie is on a different
level than kenny rogers no one likes
kenny rogers and then bob comes
like i love kenny rogers fantastic it
was really upsetting to see him die i
wanted to see more of him honestly and
it worked with winona
and i thought he was gonna make it out
of that sequence he's running around in
that jurassic park
esque episode with all the monsters
running after him which is really well
done
i thought that was the best episode of
the season but seeing him die really
upset me because i wanted more of him
and we got such a little time of him
now let me get into the bad because to
me there was a lot of bad here
a lot and i know the reviews are good of
this show but man you got to be careful
what you read because
a lot of times people are just ignoring
things and focusing only on the good
because they love the show so much other
characters and i do too
look what i'm wearing right now so i
wasn't putting a lot of pressure on you
though
i want to make sure it's clear like i'm
not one of those guys was like oh you're
expecting it to be season one again no
it was not the problem here was
it was almost just like they said
they're gonna do but it didn't work i
don't think was
taking season one and amping it up but
the problem was
is they amped it up but it was the same
ideas it wasn't like original or felt
fresh
and then you started to realize do i
really care about any of this this is
what happened to me and all the stuff i
was excited about in season two i think
never happened
because what they ended on season one
was 11 going missing
having an epic exit where she killed the
demogorgon and then you're wondering
where did she go is she alive she okay
and then you had what i was most excited
about hopper
going back with the sketchy doctors
scientists and wondering what deal did
he make to be able to go into that
upside down through them there was a
mystery behind hopper and those people
and they always seemed sketchy
and that was what i was most excited
about to see in season two is like what
are we gonna learn about hopper
what are we gonna learn about them and
then what do we learn hopper kind of
just made a plain straightforward deal
that he basically let them experiment on
will and he kind of work with them and
not
basically have them known about in the
town that he kind of cover up for them
but then we find out
the doctor's not so bad the main doctor
we see here this season he's kind of a
cool guy
and they weren't really doing much
sketchy stuff this new crew so it kind
of ran away from that mystery we had
about them that i loved in season one
and then i ran away from the mystery
about hopper because we find out really
not much new about hopper he's
just they always tease that he maybe
he's a bad guy or he's up to something
no good
but didn't go to any of that i'm not
saying i wanted to happen but the way
they were pitching last season there it
seems like there's gonna be some
element of new with him or something we
learned i feel like we didn't learn
anything and what i loved so much about
season one was the mystery
and the suspense but this season i just
felt had the suspense but no mystery and
coming with that with no mystery there's
also no big reveals
there's no twists either you need
something i thought maybe
episode six or seven it's not talking
about seven episode seven yet maybe
there'd be a huge twist
but nothing that never came that was
never a big reveal and i need that in
the show i mean you look how the show
ended last season
and it has will duking out little upside
down sludge
or demogorgon goo whatever but it got
you excited because you're like whoa
this is what's gonna happen next season
they're gonna delve into how do they end
this season
with how the poster already revealed to
us that there's a monster
in the town we already knew that and it
was hovering over us in the post season
two
and we barely got any of that monster he
never actually confronted him
and they end this season flipping us to
the upside down and seeing the monster
over them thought that was gonna happen
this season we never got
to it so now they're dragging it out and
it wasn't a big reveal it wasn't
exciting i was like really
so this whole season's villain was the
demogorgon dogs that's all we get that
was new we didn't even get to delve into
that monster he had that moment with
will's shirt he took him over but we
never had the fight they're good now
they're
dragging this monster out that lost some
excitement value here and we really
heard too was not having a human villain
that was strong like we did last season
with 11 with the match called papa he's
teased though in this season which i
like i hope he comes back we really need
him here he's a great villain
he's a human villain and he'll bring
that story back to being like what is
with
these experiments with these children we
need to get back to that with him
and add that layer to this story and
then another retread here which makes
the script feel rushed look we know we
had
they had to get this out soon people
want it and also these kids are going to
grow up we don't want
them to look too old but with joyce
winona ryder's character
okay let's replace the christmas lights
and her figuring something out with will
to now will translating with her through
coloring thing around the house oh it's
another kooky thing she's doing in the
house
and she's screaming the whole time and
worried i thought her character would
evolve a bit it did not
more of the same again so i feel like
i'm just re-watching and they're redoing
this
too much like season one and a really
annoying thing was look in the trailers
they revealed
11 was gonna come back which kind of
bothered me a bit but
that's how you get people to come back
most popular character i get it i get it
it's not the craziest thing but i
thought we'd see her reunite with people
by maybe episode four or five but we're
not gonna have that happen until episode
eight
she's with the original group what made
season one so magical
was having 11 dustin lucas and mike
together in scenes with a strong group
now it's always risky when you separate
but you can always get away with
separating one or two
but 11 was such a central part and she
just felt like a totally different
storyline here so totally separate
and you lost that edge in chemistry to
it i'm sorry max isn't going to replace
that
she was good but you needed that
supernatural character
in there with the main group of guys and
it happened
way too late and then she's with them
for what 10 minutes and leaves
give me a break like that's just not
good because 11 this central character
is with hopper and what's frustrating is
that big cliffhanger they had last
season 11 disappearing look we know
she's back
but we find out all she did was she had
this epic exit
kills a demogorgon and she just
frolicked around in the woods for a bit
and was found immediately
that's so lazy that's not like what
there's no what moment here and she's
with hopper
and the whole hopper thing in her i
didn't think they gelled i didn't think
there was good chemistry there
i think their both of their acting was
disappointing here i thought they were
both great season one
but it wasn't sold it felt off and maybe
it was just because they did not work
well together and it was dragged out to
that story and then
it was cool because it made you feel
like do i like hopper or not
is he over doing this thing with her and
they teased that that and they wanted it
but they didn't finish at that they kind
of left that hanging
so that frustrated me too and then she
leaves
after he screws up with not hanging out
with her on halloween and he's at the
hospital worrying about willing
everybody but there's already so many
people there
but he's there for like three days so
that's not realistic to me too that you
just leave
a young girl you're taking care of
that's like 12
in the woods for three days and not
checking on her that was ridiculous i
know he called her and stuff but come on
that that was not that was asking a lot
and going with 11
episode 7 this was more venus thing
where
everyone was not crazy about this
episode it's almost like oh my god what
did i just watch
i tried to stay open-minded with it but
it felt like i was watching a cw show
or a young x-men show or marvel runaways
type 5
where wait a minute there's another
person eight who
we were introduced in the beginning
which i was worried about right away
and now she was a bunch of goonies in
chicago
and it looks like the set of like a
batman movie and they look like batman
villains and they're not
believable characters over the top and i
thought the actor of
eight was terrible but she was awful not
cool
she was sucked and she was evil look i
know she's been through a lot but just
that was ruthless with her
just wanting to kill the guy with kids
and the kids are in the other room was
just like too much
and it all felt like spider-man 3 again
where you have something great with a
character like 11
and then she went to this like punk mode
and goth mode it was just like
uh like i thought maybe this kind of
story with her would work next season
but season two i thought it was early
for this i think they jumped too early
on it
we needed more time i believe with
eleven with the guys and developing her
relationship
with mike she was with mike for 10 full
minutes this season
that just stops so much on that train
and you're already jumping her
going to this dark side of her she's
tempted save that
you're jumping the gun on that with 11.
you can touch on that
in a season or two but you've got to
build your character more before that
you can't just
ride into that and i don't want to see
more of eight or that other group
because
that scared me i hope the show does not
go that direction because if this show
eventually becomes a bunch of these kids
that were experimenting on becoming a
group of rebels
you've seen it done too much it's
literally x-men do not do that
stay to your strengths you know what
really frustrated me is 11
did not like the punk thing i really
didn't that was cheesy as hell and then
when she comes back all right you're
like okay she leaves at episode seven of
those people i'm like thank god
and then she comes back and she keeps
the outfit and the hair doing something
like come on i'm not saying just look
like this what i look like all the time
or in the little kid dress but that was
just
a way high jump way too quickly it's
like if dustin just decided all of a
sudden he's gonna wear a suit every
episode just be
too much you gotta ease into changes and
adjustments so
that was really disappointing here look
she had a great epic entrance i loved
when she came back and she threw the
demi dog
through the window and then you felt
like wow this is the show it's best but
she's with this group
and then she's gone so that was a proof
for me already there that
i wanted to see more scenes with her
with the group and have the original
group together
now max i really liked max thought she
was a good actress
i liked that she was love interest of
lucas and dustin but then you start
feeling that was your only purpose
because
they did not delve in enough to all this
time and attention he gave to her and
billy in this car and
this weird mystery see that was our only
mystery and we got
no answer to it and you don't really
care about that much because you're new
characters but
you're like well what's the deal with
these two why are they behaving this way
what is this going to lead to with max
are we going to deep
get a deeper character here and we
didn't we didn't we saw billy's abused
by his parents
big whoop we've seen that story before
it's nothing groundbreaking and it's not
enough to justify how
mean he is to max and then resolve with
max threatening him
the end that's our story for the series
of that so that didn't really amount to
anything now we have to see more billy
next year's like ugh
i'm over it and a big concern i had is
mike mike was the lead character last
season
played by finn wolfhard now if you know
finn wolfhard he was also in the movie
it this year and he was incredible
because
he played a completely different
character than mike and he nailed it he
was a comic relief in that and he was
kind of like more like a bad boy it
showed me how good of an actor he is
seeing it and seeing first season
stranger things because he could play
such different roles so well
and he really took a backseat this
season and i figured that would happen a
little bit but
it was a lot here and that hurt him 911
wasn't around him and his character
because that's a central part to his
character
so they kind of didn't know what to do
with him it's kind of just their chat
with will here and there
kind of being the guy who listened to
him but he really didn't serve much of a
purpose here and i wanted to see more of
him he's a really good actor
he's funny in the show and he nails it
and it's an important character we've
attached to
but he did not get enough screen time if
you put the time together i think nancy
got more screen time
nancy and jonathan got so much screen
time here and it was torturous
that's again the feeling of a cw show
it's just as love triangle they're
developing
so people go on twitter and say if
they're harrington
and nancy or jonathan and nancy it's
just it's almost like meme bait the show
became mean bait
here knows it with the winona ryder
lines
and retreading on stuff we've already
seen starting this relationship drama
it's like come on and they ended it
originally last season where nancy
actually stuck with c which was
surprising
but they i feel like they rushed way too
out of it where she was already on to
jonathan
let that breathe a bit again it felt
like they were doing season three type
stories here in a season two of the show
you could have gone
and teased jonathan stuff in the season
because she just got with steve
and then maybe in the genre stuff
beginning of season three and then it
feels more natural and makes sense where
he was just like
why is she over steve so quick i get he
wasn't crazy with the barb thing but the
barb thing
oh my god that was led to nothing we we
meet our parents they're into
investigation sure it brings that funny
character
to journalists but it's like that was
confusing and just like okay great
i know that might lead to future stories
but then it ends with barb in the the
casket the funeral so
now if you bring her back or somehow
have her come alive it's too late it's
gonna feel stupid then i'm gonna cop
out like a jumping shark moment so i
don't know what the point of all that
was
to me it felt like fan service because
they know barb was this
so many memes t-shirts they had to just
drop some kind of resemblance to her
i really think lucas stood out this
season i thought he had a good amount of
screen time and he did great
i thought dustin was more frustrating i
know his character can serve the purpose
like that sometimes but he was
real frustrating doing a lot of stupid
things and his i don't think his humor
was
striking as well this time especially
how many times he can say the same joke
with the
look at these pearls but what was really
strong
here she felt like old stranger things
was the prom scene at the end that was
really good and i hope that's the
direction the show
goes stick with these characters keep
them together let's see them grow
together kind of like the harry potter
vibe do that strategy
these kids are gonna grow quick yeah
you're gonna have pressure make these
seasons quick but focus on them
focus on your strength of characters
because that's what made people love
season one and keep the mystery there
those two things
i felt were attacked this season and not
done well
not made the priority so i hope season
three gets back to its roots in that
sense of not
recreating story lines just keep the
crew that works together works if it's
not broken don't fix it
and add the mystery because that is a
big element to seasons one's success it
kept you on the edge of your seat and
why you know what happens the next
episode
or i felt here i didn't really care what
happened next because it's just
again an overlying monster and are they
gonna make it
and then it ends with the monsters still
out there
ugh i really wanted to like this season
but it was a huge disappointment to me
so i'm gonna give it a seven
i hope it can come back season three i
think it can
look i know a lot of people said they
enjoyed the season and it was it was
entertaining
to the standards of stranger things it
dropped a lot and i'm sure
you know it's gonna have the
sophomoritis and it's not gonna be as
good and i expected that
but i thought it would be good i don't
consider this good i thought it was not
great and not good so it was just
plain old okay which is disappointing
especially with the characters you have
and you built it just felt
lazy and rushed and not
a sense of focus or direction so i hope
they fix that
get back to the strengths and please god
bless nancy and jonathan hope you
enjoyed this review please comment below
with your thoughts on season two
stranger things
i respond to everyone i want to know
what everyone thinks let me know if you
agree disagree any thoughts you have on
the season
let me have it respond to everyone
please subscribe
i do a bunch of tv reviews movie reviews
celebrity interviews
trailer reactions podcast reactions you
name it you'll be happy you did
follow me at steve steverali1 on twitter
instagram for more and keep coming back